I'm Greg Gutfeld I'm Martha McCallum I'm
Brett Baer and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Friday November 11 2022 I'm Jared
Halpern Republicans will need to meet
expectations with a newfound majority in
the house there will be a big push from
within the party that if they don't get
some of this stuff done
um there are going to be some people who
want their money back I'm Chris Foster
psychedelic drugs are helping some
veterans deal with personal demons after
War the turnaround was so fast and it
changed my perspective it really felt
like I had lifted all this weight that I
was carrying on my shoulders you know I
was kind of excited to just live again
and I'm Andy pleasure I've got the final
word on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
as election week comes to a close it's
natural to ask now what President Biden
answered that question this week
regardless regardless of what the final
tally in these elections show and
there's still some counting going on
I'm prepared to work in my Republican
colleagues
the American people have made clear I
think that they expect Republicans to be
prepared to work with me as well the
President says he is not changing course
arguing benefits of his legislative
agenda like the infrastructure bill and
the inflation reduction act won't be
fully felt for months house Republican
whip Steve scalise who is likely to be
elevated to Majority Leader says the GOP
does have a mandate from voters pledging
his support for current GOP leader Kevin
McCarthy to take the speaker's gavel
we're going to have our elections next
week I'm supporting Kevin McCarthy for
speaker and he'll win that race and
ultimately you've seen us pull together
these last few months and focus on the
attack against big government socialism
people in very different places of
America said they don't want big
government socialism and they're going
to give us the house to be that check
and balance and we're going to go to
work for those hard-working families the
challenge now becomes governing in a
divided government with a republican
majority in the house that is on track
to be smaller than many in the party had
predicted it least publicly I think the
expectations
um you got to manage those Shannon bream
is the host of Fox News Sunday and Fox
News Chief legal Affairs correspondent
there's not a lot of managing of
expectations there was talk of a red
tsunami and of a red wave and even
though the polling we kept trying to
caution people
um the polling was within the margin of
error especially over on the Senate side
in so many of these races that we knew
there was really like absent a working
crystal ball you just couldn't know what
was going to happen and we saw real
indications that these were going to be
knocked down drag out fights on the
Senate side I think the house though is
is surprising to a lot of folks on both
sides of the aisle and certainly to the
pollsters out there
um but I think we always knew it was
going to be a slog a fight there on the
Senate side to figure out when the dust
settles how this thing's really going to
work I think what is fascinating now is
we don't know how big the Republican
majority will be we do know that it will
be pretty small right maybe the 220s
range it looks like
um what are you hearing about what that
means for the likely next speaker Kevin
McCarthy I don't hear and you either
you're all over the hill
um you may know better than I do but I
don't hear of any real substantive
challenges being mounted to him as
Speaker I think what's going to happen
is if you become speaker as expected
he's gonna have a lot of wrangling over
there with the freedom caucus and other
people who are you know or to the
farther right of the party who are going
to immediately start calling from
impeachments and that kind of thing can
he manage that so they have a unified
voice on the things that they want to
try to accomplish listen you've got a
president with a veto pen there's only
so much you can do but you don't want to
waste the two years acting like you're
doing nothing for the American people
um I think there'll be messaging bills
just like Democrats do where they're
like look we put this thing up we passed
this and the president won't sign it
when we all know he's not going to sign
it but you got to look like you're
governing and doing the actual work or
the people will punish you Republicans
also now will have the power of the
subpoena
mm-hmm and I think that could be a real
headache for the White House you heard
the president talk about this Wednesday
afternoon when somebody asks about the
hunter because I think you're going to
hear a lot about the Border calls to
impeach secretary mayorkas you're going
to hear a lot about Hunter Biden you're
getting an FBI director FBI
um
I mean Jim Jordan is going to be busy
because I think he has a lot of plans
for a lot of hearings um you know
senator Paul is talking about Dr fauci
if uh Republicans somehow you know get
the upper hand in the Senate I think
you'll see a lot of Dr fauci Who at
least calls for him whether he you know
goes into full retirement or doesn't
show up that's a whole nother fight over
subpoenas or anything else
um but I think they're very focused on
these investigations and you heard the
president say when asked about Hunter an
investigation say well I think the
American people are ready for us to move
on get some things done for them and he
says it's almost like a comedy well Jim
Jordan at all do not think so and they
will be sending out some requests to
appear do you think that that is a
mandate I mean is that where the country
is too
I think it's where Jim Jordan's
constituency if you if you're more me
more broadly not just I mean because
that was one of the the sort of
cautionary tales from Democrats right is
you know let's not go too far here with
some of these Trump hearings and and the
impeachment right I mean and so there is
sort of a thought of like do Republicans
sort of come out and say you know what
was good for the goose is good for the
gander and you know start moving in that
direction or is there sort of thing yeah
I think they've been itching they've
been itching to get that gavel and get
those subpoenas and listen there are
people they have gone on all forms of
radio and TV and ads and everything else
to say if you give us the power we're
going to do these investigations there
will be a big push from within the party
that if they don't get some of this
stuff done
um there are going to be some people who
want their money back
well and the other issue too is I mean
we have to do this again in two years
um and you have it's never over well
it's not I mean but my point
keeps me gainfully employed but you uh
exactly you have
um a lot of these Republicans who flip
seats right in in sort of swingy
flippable seats and the decisions
they're going to have to make are going
to be based on I gotta run in this same
district in this same flippable seat in
two years right right yeah and and those
are hard to hold on to yeah so I guess
it's just you wonder like what is going
to get done legislatively right they
they have to I don't think a whole lot
well I mean what do they do with Ukraine
Aid I mean they're gonna have to find a
way forward on that I mean they're going
to name mailboxes post offices they're
going to try to get stuff done hopefully
for vets they're going to do funding
measures enough to keep things open as
you know as our listeners know the money
runs out December 16th under the current
federal spending mechanism so in a lame
duck session they're gonna have to
figure that out there will be things
they have to get done for the country to
stop keep operating
um but there are threats already about
the debt ceiling and listen the house
controls the pocketbook so that's the
one place Republicans are likely to have
some power but you don't see much of a
ground here for comprehensive
immigration reform no I mean I I hate to
say it I hate to say it but then who
does that benefit if they get it done it
would benefit the country it would
benefit the country to figure out that
situation but um going into a 2024
election I think that um Republicans
probably are not going to want to give
the White House a big win
and the White House is not going to want
to give you know the legislative bodies
or body controlled by the Republicans a
win but that's where you got to hope
that people rise above and think all
right this is a massive problem for
decades in this country the border is
completely out of control according to
Democrats and Republicans and neutral
observers down there
um and the people who are caught up in
the middle of it are human beings and
their lives are being lost there too so
if you care about Humanity you might
want to get on that let me finish with
this and this is sort of a supreme court
question so I'm glad that you're here
um how big an impact did the Supreme
Court have in these midterms
I think uh it was outsized honestly if
you think about the Dobbs decision that
got rid of Roe v Wade that clearly fired
up the Democrats base we saw them surge
over the summer um on the Congressional
generic ballot and other places and they
banked a lot of that vote early I mean
when weeks ago in a number of states
things opened up they were still
hammering the airwaves with that message
and I think in states where the abortion
question was on the ballot it was very
good for Democrats too and drove their
base to get out in those States so um I
think the Supreme Court's decision in
Dobbs listen it's what pro-lifers have
been fighting for for roughly half a
century
um but it may have had some significant
costs for pro-life causes if you look at
that in light of conservative
wins and losses in the midterms what do
we have uh on Fox News Sunday this
weekend
you know what we had a plan
where leadership on both sides of the
aisle we're trying to nail down who
comes to join us
um but we're gonna you know do some
we've got a fantastic panel like always
um to do a very deep dive on exactly
what happened and polls and those kinds
of things but you're gonna hear from our
reporters too we're trying to add more
of kind of a reporters Roundtable
um and what they were seeing and hearing
on the campaign Trail did it match up
with the polls or not
um and we'll talk 2024 because it's that
time it's gonna start right away uh I
will be watching Shannon bream the
anchor of Fox News Sunday I love our
chess thanks for joining us I do too
thank you Jared
[Music]
foreign this is Andy puzder with your
Fox News commentary coming up
most psychedelic drugs are illegal under
federal law a lot of people still use
them recreationally and increasingly
therapeutically for treatment of mental
health problems like depression and
post-traumatic stress disorder the
Department of Veterans Affairs has
clinical trials going with the support
of amendments sponsored by New York
house Democrat Alexandria ocasio-cortez
and Texas house Republican Dan Crenshaw
a veteran wounded in Afghanistan
research was first conducted at the VA
in the 60s when scientists considered
psychedelics and potential Game Changer
and treating psychiatric conditions but
as recreational use increase the studies
were abandoned until recently when the
VA re-implemented the program last
summer after FDA and DEA approval Marcus
Capone was a Navy SEAL dealing with
post-traumatic stress disorder and a
traumatic brain injury we call it a mild
TBI because it's really you know mtbi
and at the time I think all of us were
avoiding the term PTSD you know I still
avoid the term today he and his wife
Amber promote and sponsor psychedelic
therapy for veterans after his positive
experience I don't like to be labeled
with the post-traumatic stress label but
I was definitely struggling with all the
symptoms that fall underneath those
categories so I was starting to become
really agitated angry depressed
um I wasn't sleeping well you know we
had lost a lot of individuals from 2006
to 2010 some very close friends and uh
you know it was just I was just getting
tired
um I started seeing some therapists uh
during that time and I was actually put
on my first antidepressant in 2010 and I
stayed on prescription medicines a host
of them through 2017 you know once you
start on that path it's difficult to
stop so you I mean you were taking an
active role in your in your treatment
Amber I'm sure you were there too and
you probably you probably thought once
he was done okay look he's out fresh
start new life he'll feel better now I
definitely thought that I definitely got
that and we were we actually attended a
retirement ceremony for a seal that
Marcus served with recently and I you
know just sitting there and seeing this
family this precious family that has
given so much and how excited they were
to finally get their dad back their
husband back and knowing the struggle
that we went through on the other side
of service you know it really is a time
in someone's life where you should be so
excited and so optimistic about the
future and I was that but there were no
resources on the other side so it was
enormously challenging
let me fast forward from this dark
tunnel to five years ago Veterans Day
2017 and you said everything changed was
it just like a switch yeah you know I
came to a point where I was just
frustrated uh five different brain
centers a multitude of prescription meds
and this was uh we seemed to think it
was the last ditch effort I tried
hyperbaric oxygen therapy I've tried TMS
and you know nothing seemed to work for
me and
um the more I read about psychedelic
medicine the more it made sense that
these are medicines that are used for
recreation just like anything else can
be used but these are medicines first
and so the more research I did the more
it made sense and so I just you know I
took a chance and I went to a reputable
clinic in Mexico and I hate to use the
word Panacea but I mean the turnaround
was so fast and um it changed my
perspective it really felt like I had
lifted all this weight that I was
carrying on my shoulders you know I was
kind of excited to just live again and
the first thing I did was to tell Amber
I said this is exactly what our you know
my teammates need I know a lot of them
were suffering a lot of them were
reaching out and trying to figure out
where they can get help and so we just
wanted to pay it forward that's that's
really all we wanted to do and we had no
idea it was going to turn into uh where
we're at today tell me what the drug is
called ibogaine do we call it a drug
yeah I mean I don't know what you had
how you classified a medicine a drug you
know it is extracted from the aboga root
which grows in West Africa and you know
it's been used in uh certain African
cultures for thousands of years for
Rites of Passage for you know stomach
ailments for mental health and
um it's also being studied for uh
addiction so opioid addiction alcohol
use disorder and uh what the drug does
like many of the other classic
psychedelics you know puts you into an
awakened dream state and it flashes
really your life before you
um the joke is you can't hide from the
medicine it's going to pull out what it
needs to and the things that are
affecting you in your subconscious maybe
that you're not even thinking about the
things that are affecting you in your
daily life uh the the drug actually
makes you go back and potentially
revisit those so you revisit potentially
childhood traumas or you visit you know
wartime traumas and you deal with those
as you know you can't overcome uh
problems unless you do built them head
on and that's what the drug does and
when you deal with that you're able to
move on you're able to kind of bury the
hatchet is this is it sort of like a
does it feel like a hard reset or is
there some sort of Maintenance therapy
so it's it's a complete reset it
disrupts your default mode in in certain
ways so your default mode you and I you
know we're protected it protects us you
know the oven's hot uh don't touch the
oven you touch it one time you're not
going to do it again or you have these
rumination thoughts you know I'm no good
I can't do anything right
um I walk in a room with a lot of people
everyone's staring at me right these are
the thoughts that keep going on in our
minds we've all had them some of them of
course for people are really bad and
they need to take medicine for that well
the Psychedelic medicine cuts that
thought pattern and it allows you to to
move away from that thought pattern and
generate new thought patterns that can
be positive and that's the power of some
of these medicines I'd also
um say that Marcus has put in a ton of
hard work on the other side of it so
it's certainly it felt like a miracle
cure at the time because nothing had
worked and this was so rapid and so
intense it certainly seemed like a
Panacea but some of Marcus's hardest
days came after the journey because he
was still processing and so by
continuing to go back to the well and
really deal with the things that were
affecting him subconsciously five years
later he still continues to improve and
by the way there's no Finish Line on
this journey on this trip it's a
continual Improvement for the rest of
his life but psychedelics got him from a
really dark sort of self-destructive
Place back on his feet and he's taken it
from there what's the pushback from
either one of you is it concern the
pushback in terms of why this stuff is
illegal in the United States is a
concern is about safety ignorance
concerns about efficacy or is it just
you know the stigma of we don't want you
getting high
I would say it's probably both I would
say it's probably rooted in lack of
Education these substances were grouped
alongside heroin cocaine methamphetamine
I think that once we can destigmatize
psychedelics and humanize the messaging
science will prove that they are far
more efficacious than anything currently
available and I think that the other
pushback would be these treatments are
like once in a lifetime to once a year
you know they're very infrequent and
when you have lifetime subscribers to
the pharmaceutical model that's a threat
in a very different way yeah do you
think that there's to be cynical about
it is there behind the scenes or not
behind the scenes pushback from Pharma
against this stuff it's against their
financial interests certainly you know
at the heart of it I want to think that
people are are good people Chris I think
what Farmer's going to do is going to
say okay here's a new drug that works
we're going to figure out a way to get
involved right I don't think they're
going to say well you know we're going
to continue pushing Prozac and other
antidepressants and moose stabilers down
people's throats because that's the way
we can make money I think if there's
something that comes to Market that
works I think they're just going to
figure out a way to get involved so I
don't think there's nefarious activity
but that's my that's my the hope at
least yeah I mean it might actually be I
mean yeah I mean it could be a good
thing if if Acme drug company comes up
with a way to you know safely in cheap
we produce this stuff then then you know
maybe so much the better in the meantime
you guys I've started this organization
called vets veterans exploring Treatment
Solutions tell me what you're doing to
get people access to this stuff
as Mark has mentioned earlier one of the
first things he said to me after I saw
him following his abigaine journey was
this is exactly what my teammates need
and we didn't really know what that
would look like but we started raising
money for our friends of course we were
doing this without a real clear
indication of what the efficacy rates
would be or if the results were to last
and so for about a year we had this
Grassroots movement where we really
didn't want to talk about it our
community was struggling but it was also
at that point very stigmatized to say
we're struggling and at about the 11 and
a half month Mark of this one we wanted
one year to go by before we would be
courageous enough to speak out or take
next steps
one of Marx's former teammates and one
of my best friend's husbands took his
life and from that point forward we just
decided this is it we've got to speak
out we've got to figure this out and so
we put together a dedicated organization
which is now vets we obtained our 501c3
status and we provide funding for other
veterans who unfortunately are having to
leave our country to travel abroad for
access to meaningful care and we are
really starting to pick up our advocacy
efforts primarily on Capitol Hill to
really enact long-term change we're very
limited as an organization how many
individuals we can help any given year
150 to 250 there are hundreds of
thousands of veterans that could benefit
from this so we're really compelled to
move the needle on the legislative front
Okay well the risk of getting you maybe
maybe a little more attention than uh
than you can handle at the time go to
vetsolutions.org if you want to help out
the Capones uh in the organization or if
you need some help or if you know
somebody who need some help Marcus and
Amber Capone thank you very much it's
good to talk to you thank you Chris
thanks so much
[Music]
listen to the all-new Brett Bear podcast
featuring Common Ground in-depth talks
with lawmakers from opposite sides of
the aisle along with all your bear
favorites like his All-Star panel and
much more available now at
foxnewspodcasts.com or wherever you get
your podcasts subscribe to this podcast
at foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for
your Fox News commentary Andy puster
what's on your mind polls are closed
across the country and it seems clear
the Republicans will take control of at
least House of Representatives and they
have a shot in control of the Senate
while there was no red tsunami
Republicans made gains and thankfully we
will likely have a divided government
for the remainder of the Biden
presidency
so what does that mean for working in
Middle Class Americans what can
Republicans do to turn the economy
around with only one perhaps two houses
of Congress as it turns out they can do
quite a lot let's look at what might
play out economically under each of the
likely post-election scenarios first
with the majority in at least the House
of Representatives Republicans can put
an end to the Democrats passing the
massive spending spree legislation
that's been driving inflation and
crushing American families such as the
bloated American Rescue plan and the
ironically named inflation reduction Act
should Republicans win both the house
and the Senate they could use the
reconciliation process which avoids the
filibuster and allows the Senate to pass
fiscal legislation on just a majority
vote to pass pro-growth legislation
Biden would then be forced to either
veto the legislation as Clinton did with
the Republican passed tax cuts in 1995
or sign it into law as Clinton did with
welfare reform
if that is ultimately the case I would
expect Republicans to focus on energy
and crime energy is both a jobs and an
anti-inflation issue with substantial
National Security overtones
given Tuesday night's election results
and the genuine crises facing our nation
there are likely Senate Democrats who
would support measures in both areas
maybe not enough to defeat a filibuster
but enough to make those issues
genuinely bipartisan that's the kind of
bipartisanship Americans have been
hoping for this is an opportunity for
both political parties to deliver
even with control of just the House
Republicans can also start turning the
tide on excessive government spending
and inflation inflation in the economy
consistently pulled as the number one
issue on the minds of Voters and we're a
deciding factor in a number of otherwise
close races two ways House Republicans
can address excessive spending are
government funding by Tradition general
Appropriations bills originate in the
house and Appropriations is where most
policy fights will happen over the next
two years
it's also where Republicans will have
maximum leverage Biden's government
needs taxpayer money in order to do
anything Republicans should rein in
spending levels and also cut off harmful
spending that funds the left's agenda
cutting back on funding for some of
Biden's spending and tax giveaways to
Green energy programs would be a great
place to start
the treasury will hit the 31.2 trillion
debt limit next year this is an absurd
amount of debt particularly with
interest rates Rising increasing the
debt limit has historically served as a
leverage point for doing something about
spending Going Back 40 years any
agreement on a debt limit should be
paired with spending cuts and reforms
that address our nation's underlying
problem
unsustainable spending
all of this points to a better stronger
economy with Republicans in control of
one or both houses of Congress elections
matter because policy matters and as the
last 21 months demonstrate it matters a
lot I'm Andy puzder former CEO of cke
restaurants
[Music]
we've been listening to the Fox News
rundown now and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcasts
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
from the Fox News podcasts Network my
name is Kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will I humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's Kennedy Saves the World
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com